hi reject nation it's Greg and I'm John
so this video dropped a couple days ago
for my good friend
Aldo Jones you Italian son-of-a-bitch
here over the weekend I was pretty sick
a little under the weather but let's
catch up on some videos now shall we
with Aldo Jones The Lion King weird
Trello Trello Trello rent Trello read
before we do that I want to say thank
you to all who have followed us and
Stardust APO over there we do 30 second
reaction reviews for films TV shows and
trailers we are at 7.6 K followers it's
a damn good year to be alive am i right
for us I don't know about your guys's
life I hope it's good
anyhow we post daily on there we post a
lot actually and who mean a lot if you
could follow us and yeah plugging
ourselves let's do this okay
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
okay and will rise with you no oh good
yes Willis is scary
holy hood why is it like a patron or
something
ah so then yeah boy you're free Rud I
gotta like crack open a pomegranate like
smear this for I can't hear you there
that founds a pretty loud John the joke
I made just now a cousin moccasins
[Music]
that's like a man so is that the gym and
John texted me that the discussion
portion about Aldo Jones's trailer you
know when you try to come up with a lot
of cool things to say about Aldo Jones's
weird trailer all that had no audio now
we're gonna have to recreate that exact
momentum as if we just watched it we
just we just we just why this is fresh
off the presses man we just rewatched it
so we can give good commentary honest
feet bonus feedback no weird momentum
has occurred now hey you know that one
thing we just saw just now with Jim
Carrey poking out that rhinos butthole
you know that is actually a favorite
comedy moment of mine of Jim Carrey that
I don't think enough people talk about I
think when nature calls is one of Jim
Carrey's most underrated comedies
because it's not great it's not better
than the first one
there's some pretty funny moments in
that belt and he's coming out of that
rhinos but that cracks me up but what's
interesting about Aldo Jones's trailer
here it seemed to blend really well like
a lot of the things maybe because of the
fact that it's so CGI every everything
is CGI in this Lion King trailer why
don't I say it's an animated movie
exactly just like on movie exactly is it
fair to call the new Lion King movie
live Al damn it okay so the fact that
it's so animated and Aldo Jones is mixed
in his weirdness in there it seems to
mesh well all his random inserts with
the rock val kilmer yeah all those
things even like having like having a
rhino there Jim Carrey coming out of it
actually does it seem like this look
like an insert so it kind of does what
it's a bit yeah because at first I was
sitting there going oh did he just
insert Jim Carrey into a rhino that was
already there and then I realized oh
wait no this is from a larger yes
there's something about that too with
like the movement of the mouths is like
these are all CG and animals so that
even looks better when he's swapping out
symbols like for appease everybody yeah
speaking of Peters so much toilet humor
from the Jonesy in here man the bass
videos about this is the most lowbrow
humor
we've ever seen that Italian hunk ever
dude yeah man I mean first the lion
steps on some poop steps in a Duke which
is something I do quite frequently
intentionally I think that when I do do
that
a lot of people will be like what's that
smell and I'm a guy who loves attention
so I'm like oh I stepped in poop feel
sorry for me the best kind of attention
is getting pity so if you can get pity
as often as possible
Stefon some poop people kind of pity
that you get when you stepped in poop
yeah the the pinnacle when I talking
about heartbreak I'm not talking about
loss of something
Stephon poop oh all right way to get
pity poor guy no one wants to be around
you yeah because it keeps intentionally
doing it the toilet humor here though
are you like even with Simba peeing and
he's on sip first Simba pees and then
he's peeing on Stifler space he says
yeah and I Here I am sitting there going
I think you could have done a whole
medley of piss in the face moments
because there's that great moment from
that movie where Jackie Chan and Jet Li
team up deadly pees on Jackie Chan yeah
yeah yeah that was the mashup we all
waited for so many more moments like
that that he could have added in if only
if only out of jokes imagine although
but no the joint is a meatballs
I even think these sequences here worked
pretty well they flow really well it
would scrap from Ice Age with the ice
breaking and then it breaks Pride Rock
off I thought it was a really nice
addition to it it seems like the
sequences were well done yeah yeah what
even that you think like well Ice Age is
just a movie about animated animals and
an animated environment so really if you
just updated the CGI this could just be
in this movie yeah exactly
that's why it worked so well sometimes
al dojos will really hyper extend out
some bits so you often get a weird
trailer that is significantly longer
than the actual trailer yeah but this
one is not significantly longer than the
actual trailer is only some minor
extensions here or there but in terms of
like other sequences I really loved how
we they threw it bleeding gums Murphy
from decision oh yeah in the clouds
yeah because that was when I was a kid
really um I saw that episode
that moment really stood out to me
because I was the first time it hit me
that the same guy who voices Mufasa is
the same guy who voices Darth Vader yeah
I never put that together yeah I don't
mind wasn't like study who voice actors
or whatever like that
no James Earl Jones was with that
remember that that's why I mobile really
stood out to me I'm top of that it's
just a really sad episode for Lisa
Simpson that day but it works here and I
like the expansion to of bully McGuire
because like he were so used to seeing
bully McGuire the Aldo Jones videos you
know you're just doing the dance but
he's in here right yeah he's on the
ridge where the wildebeests are running
yeah yeah before they killed Mufasa so
there's the dance moment of bully
McGuire but then to replace the voice of
older Simba with James Franco from
Spidey and then you get bully McCoy and
you just put that scene in there so I
felt like there were actual good
sequences in here you seem to flow
pretty well with what this weird trailer
is and I did a great job with it
it was really funny stuff man always
looking forward to smile some people
think it's good like we're really
stretching here when we try to talk
about how though Jen's weird shred but
when a guy puts this much work into it
I'm gonna try to dissect it I'm gonna
try to put some commentary on it cuz at
least I can do this he'll ask us to
check out his videos and when we do them
like this daily things take time and I
know that he's old it's not just what's
funny here what's playing here he's
going for stuff so it's fun to try to
like dissect what he's doing or
deconstruct what he's doing you know
yeah I don't know if we're doing a good
job were the official audio Jones
after-show we're like the talking dead
we literally could have just ended their
reaction and then just filmed the end
part here and said subscribe but we like
no we like talking about what he does
and I think he does a great job so now
though keep it up man this was some
there's a really funny weird trailer
dude alright guys well you can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification bell and what do we shout
at the top of this video
Oh Stardust and download and follow us
on the Stardust app we do stuff there
yep the bye
you